we are now ready to move on to a model
which is quite interesting and quite
realistic this is a model in which we
have an unknown parameter model it is a
random variable that we try to estimate
this is the random variable theta and we
have multiple observations of that
random variable each one of those
observations is equal to the unknown
random variable plus some additive noise
this is a model that appears quite often
in practice it is often the case that we
are trying to estimate a certain
quantity but we can only observe values
of that quantity in the presence of
noise and because of the noise what we
want to do is to try to measure it
multiple times and so we have multiple
such measurement equations and then we
want to combine all the observations
together to come up with a good estimate
of that parameter the assumptions that
we will be making are that theta is a
normal random variable it has a certain
mean that we denote by x0 the reason for
the strange notation will be seen later
and it also has a certain variance the
noise terms are also normal random
variables with zero mean and a certain
variance and finally we assume that
these basic random variables that define
our model are all independent based on
these assumptions now we would like to
estimate theta on the basis of the X's
and as usual in the Bayesian setting
what we want to do is to calculate the
posterior distribution of theta given
the XS the Bayes rule has the usual form
for the case of continuous random
variables the only remark that needs to
be made is that in this case there are
multiple X's so X up here stands for the
vector of the observations that we have
obtained
and similarly little X will stand for
the vector of the values of these
observations so we need now to start
making some progress towards calculating
this term here what is the distribution
of the
door of measurements given theta before
we move to the vector case let us look
at one of the measurements in isolation
this is something that we have already
seen if I tell you the value of the
random variable theta which is what
happens in this conditional universe
when you condition on the value of theta
then in that universe the random
variable X I is equal to the numerical
value that you gave me for theta plus WI
and because WI is independent from the
random variable theta knowing the value
of the random variable theta does not
change the distribution of WI it will
still have this normal distribution so X
I is a normal of this kind plus a
constant and so X I is a normal random
variable with mean equal to the constant
that we added and variance equal to the
original variance of the random variable
WI and so we can now write down the PDF
the conditional PDF of X I there's going
to be a normalizing constant and then
the usual exponential term which is
going to be X I minus the mean of the
distribution which is theta and then we
divide by the usual variance term let us
move next to this distribution here this
is a shorthand notation for the joint
PDF of the random variables x1 up to X n
conditional on the random variable theta
so it's really a function of multiple
variables and how do we proceed now here
is the crucial observation if I tell you
the value of the random variable capital
theta
as before then you argue as follows all
these random variables are independent
so if I tell you the value of the random
variable theta this does not change the
Joint Distribution of the W is the Wis
were independent when we started so they
remain independent in the conditional
universe and since the W is are
independent and the x i's are obtained
from the Wis by just adding a constant
this means that the x i's are also
independent in this conditional universe
once I tell you the value of theta then
because the noises are independent the
observations are also independent but
this means that the joint PDF factors
has a product of the individual marginal
PDFs of the x i's and these pdfs we have
already found so now we can put
everything together to write down a
formula for the posterior PDF using the
Bayes rule we have this denominator term
which I will write first and which term
we do not need to evaluate then we have
the marginal PDF of theta now since
theta is normal with these parameters
this is of the form e to the minus theta
minus x0 squared over 2 Sigma 0 squared
and then we have this joint density of
the axis conditioned on theta which we
have already found it is this product
here it's a product of n terms one for
each observation and each one of these
terms is what we have found
earlier so I'm just substituting this
expression up here now once we have
obtained the observations so the value
of the random variable capital X that is
the value little X is fixed once it is
fixed then the X's that appear here are
constant so in particular this term here
is a constant we do not bother with it
and what we have is a constant times an
exponential in terms that are quadratic
in theta so we recognize this kind of
expression it has to correspond to a
normal distribution and this is the
first conclusion of this exercise that
is the posterior PDF of the parameter
theta given our observations this
posterior PDF is normal we have e to a
quadratic function in theta and that
quadratic function also involves the
specific values of the axes that we have
obtained let us copy what we have found
and rearrange it once more we have a
constant then the exponential of the
negative of some quadratic function in
theta and the specific quadratic
function that we calculated just before
takes this particular form what is the
mean of this normal distribution the
mean is the same as the peak and to find
the peak the location at which this PDF
is largest what we do is we try to find
the place at which this quadratic
function is smallest so what we do is to
take the derivative with respect to
theta of this quadratic and set it to
zero this gives us a sum
terms the derivative of the typical term
is going to be theta minus X I divided
by Sigma I squared and this expression
must be equal to zero if theta is at the
peak of the posterior distribution and
so we now rearrange this equation we
split and take first the term involving
theta and gives us a contribution of
this kind and we move the terms
involving X s to the other side and this
gives us this expression
and finally we take this sum here and
send it to the denominator of the other
side and this gives us the final form of
the solution the peak of the posterior
distribution which is also the same as
the conditional expectation of the
posterior distribution whenever we have
a normal distribution the expected value
is the same as the place where the
distribution is largest let us now
conclude with a few comments and words
about how to interpret the result that
we found first let me emphasize that the
same conclusion that we have obtained
for the case of a single observation go
through in this case as well the
posterior distribution of the unknown
parameter is still a normal distribution
our state of knowledge about theta
after we obtain the observations is
described by a normal distribution
because it is a normal distribution the
location of its peak is the same as the
expected value and for this reason the
conditional expectation estimate and the
maximum a-posteriori probability
estimates coincide and finally the form
of the estimates that we get is a linear
function in the x i's and this linearity
is a very convenient property to have
because it allows further analysis of
these ways of obtaining estimates how do
we interpret this formula what we have
here is the following each one of the x
i's gets multiplied by a certain
coefficient which is 1 over the variance
and in the denominator we have the sum
of all those coefficients so what we
really have here is a weighted average
of the x i's now keep in mind that those
x i's are not all of them of the same
kind one term is x0 which is the prior
mean whereas the remaining x i's are the
values of the observations so there's
something interesting
opening here we combine the values of
the observations with the value of the
prior mean and in some sense the prior
mean is treated as just one more piece
of information available to us and it is
treated in the sort of equal way as the
other observations the weight that we
have in these weighted average are that
each X I gets divided by the
corresponding variance does this make
sense
well suppose that Sigma I squared is
large this means that the noise term WI
is very large so X I is very noisy and
so it's not a useful observation to have
and in that case it gets a small weight
so the weights are determined by the
variances in a way that is quite
sensible those observations that will
get the most weight will be those
observations for which the corresponding
noise variance is small so the solution
to this estimation problem that we just
went through has many nice properties
first we stay within the world of normal
random variables because even the
posterior is normal we stay within the
world of linear functions of normal
random variables and the form of the
formula that we have itself has an
appealing intuitive content